Hello Freak bitches.
Um,
I got the interesting thing.
So daring me asking me what the last time,
I believe you,
you've got a pile of notes.
What is it about breathing?
What is it about breathing
or his breathing?
Just one component of this.
Is it breathing and also focusing
on what you're trying to accomplish?
Yeah,
focus absolutely works.
Let me explain a little about,
uh,
about breathing.
Breathing is chemistry.
Oxygen has chemistry in the body,
so if you all are able to,
uh,
Oksana dies,
the sells more than we do normally because
we talked about the lymphatic system
and the tissue and actually the,
uh,
the body's able to store up more oxygen
than the hundred percent we presumed,
uh,
possible is scientifically,
we are able to store up more oxygen.
So Ava breathing technique,
whatever breathing technique is able
to store up more oxygen into cell,
that means going into the tissue,
going into the lymphatic system.
Then suddenly the,
Eh,
the chemistry becomes alkaline.
The acid gets out of the body
at will and then the mind,
the mind is positive,
a little electrical charges,
neurotransmitters and eh,
they are suddenly able to connect in
a buddy and you enabling you to have
control and direct all
the systems in the body.
That's the way nature manda to be.
So the mind,
a mind condition to be effective
in the body is making the body,
uh,
by breath,
right breathing profound
breathing in an alkaline state.
Then these electrical signals
are able to travel through.
And we,
the way nature meant it to be is that
we are able to direct any part of the
body.
So the immune system,
endocrine system,
their lymphatic system,
vasculars older systems where
we told a little bit last time,
but I get more direct evidence now.
Um,
uh,
right now we are working with the
universities on the brain on say,
emotional reactivity and
they see incredible things
that we actually are able to
get into those places where
emotion exists and we take emotion,
where is it,
where is it?
But at this translated also as something
chemical so they can measure motion and
the chemical form.
Yes.
What are they,
what are they measuring?
And they,
they go into say a the hypothalamus,
hypothalamus,
hippocampus,
Amygdala.
Those are the places where this chemistry
is going on and we had no way to get
into that.
Now,
if you are able to ox energize those
parts and to pressurize with breathing
techniques into those parts,
then suddenly you feel you begin cry.
Why?
Because the chemistry is changing.
You are dealing with a chemistry which
was stored up because he couldn't work it
out before and now you're
able to tap in there,
change the chemistry and
that that's the function.
Uh,
you are not able to deal with it now.
So later when you have peace and you are,
uh,
somewhere,
no,
not stressful,
then work on it and breathing does it,
it eh,
Eh,
eh,
positively influences
the chemistry in the,
Eh,
in the depth of the brain.
You know,
what happens?
You create 25% more blood flow and
blood flow is with oxygen through three
breathing.
Yes.
Well it makes sense because
your blood is being,
it's carrying oxygen,
right?
So the more oxygen you provide your
blood and you are definitely providing it
more with these big long,
deep breaths and these techniques
at you that you pursue.
Yes,
manipulating up the spine,
the central nervous system up
till the tunnel of the light.
The brainstem is at top.
So if you pressure rise
after act inhaling,
exhaling like we did last time you
did about three minutes almost uh,
without uh,
in the lungs.
Very good.
First round is very promising for the
next round because you get more and more
oxygen.
It only to show that you are able to
store a up oxygen far more than you ever
used before.
So in case when you need it to
regulate the chemistry inside the body,
then it needs oxygen.
Daniel,
we are all able with these breathing
exercises to get it anywhere where the
chemistry is messed up and
a chemistry master APP,
we'll send off a signal but we are not
emotionally not listening because we got
a worries and we need to do
to deadline and this and that.
So we are not a,
and then there's chemistry
stays over there and,
and will deregulate the system and then
we become sick and we don't know what's
happening.
We go to the doctor and uh,
or the psychiatrist because we
could become depressed and all.
But I,
we are very able to get into any
place in the body and in this case,
the brain,
uh,
where,
and we do all the studies
now with the university.
They say cognitive therapy just talking
to each other in the psychology and
psychotherapy.
That's not enough.
That was a conference with 200 experts
and they did this breathing and then they
say,
oh,
wow,
yeah,
talking a only is not enough.
But if you do this breathing,
then you really get into the brain and
then suddenly you get a sense of control
because you're creating this
extra circulation of blood.
Yes,
Eh,
to get her with oxygen,
making it alkaline.
Then suddenly the blockage is created
because of Ron chemistry because of trauma
or,
uh,
anxiety or grief.
Then suddenly a,
that chemistry is being dealt
with and you get balanced.
[inaudible] simple.
And we keep it simple,
uh,
and,
and try to get this web of our thoughts.
Thinking of so many
difficulties and complications,
what is emotion?
What is fair?
What is PTSD?
What is trauma?
What is depression?
We don't know where it is in the brain.
Just get older brain full of oxygen,
get to alkalinity up and you are able
to steer by going through the spine,
up in your head and do it all.
Is that why sit do you believe,
is that why some studies have
shown that rigorous exercise,
particularly cardio like
running a elliptical machines,
things along those lines are just as
good for depression as medication?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It,
it's dealing with the oxygen tension
forcing when you think those giant deep
breaths you take when you're jogging or,
yes.
Yes,
I do.
Uh,
when you do though,
staying,
see,
you actually create a dead body
to be effective with the oxygen,
then subtly different
mechanisms are at work,
Eh,
more oxygen is coming in and
the chemistry is balancing out.
A depression is caused by a,
a wrong chemistry,
creating inflammation.
I,
you know,
I'm a regular exerciser,
but sometimes,
yeah.